and this must be so frustrating this
idea of foo fighters being grounded
because nothing
stops you guys i mean even your broken
leg
did not stop you well i was uh
yeah i fell off the stage and i broke my
leg well i mean here's the thing
is that you still singing while your
leg is being set yes
[Laughter]
[Music]
basically what happened if we were it
was a stadium
in sweden and it was like 60 000 people
there we were two songs into the set
and i and like a clown i fall off the
stage
shatter my dislocate my ankle tear all
believements to break a bone
and i try to stand and there's nothing
there
so we stopped the show and i say to my
drummer just keep playing
play a queen song play a queen song and
they they pull me off to the side
in a gurney and the guy says ankle's
dislocated i got to put it back in right
now
so i said i'm like i said to my tour
manager i said get me a whiskey
my wife is sitting next to me i put her
leather jacket in my mouth and i bit as
hard as i could
and the guy puts my ankle back in and so
i'm sitting there
and i feel i'm an adrenaline and whiskey
i don't feel a thing
so i just i'm like i that same man that
you see holding my leg right there
i look at him and i say okay well can i
go up and finish the show
and he goes no because if i let go of
your ankle it's just gonna fall out
and i said well then you're coming on
stage with me right now so we went up on
stage and we did another by
two and a half hours and then i said
okay where's the ambulance
get me out of here and then yeah phew
you